Transcription: Diana Simões
Relecteur: eric vautier
Cette fois,
c’est sûr, il y a urgence.
C'est l'urgence climatique.
On a tous en tête
les incendies de cet été,
la crise énergétique,
le réchauffement climatique.
Notre maison brûle.
Il faut agir pour protéger notre planète.
On est tous d'accord avec ça.
Mais notre planète,
est-ce qu’on la connaît vraiment ?
Est-ce qu’on la connaît bien ?
Quand on parle de planète,
on imagine déjà aller sur Mars,
aller vivre sur Mars,
avec une étape en passant sur la Lune.
Mars, c’est la planète rouge.
Et nous, on a la planète bleue.
Et pourquoi elle est bleue ?
Parce que 70% de la surface de la Terre,
c’est l’océan.
70% de la surface
de la Terre, c’est l’océan.
Alors pourquoi on n’est pas sur Mars ?
Il y en a qui ont déjà essayé
de respirer sur Mars ?
Bon, ici c’est plus facile,
on a de l’oxygène,
Il vient d’où, l’oxygène ?
C’est quoi, le poumon de la planète ?
Allez-y !
La forêt.
Exactement, l’océan.
L’océan, c’est une respiration sur deux.
Ok, on va essayer.
Allez-y, respirez !
Ça, c’est la forêt.
Respirez !
Ça, c’est l’océan.
On a tous compris.
Et l’océan, c’est le poumon de la planète,
il produit plus d’oxygène que la forêt.
Vous allez me dire :
« Le réchauffement climatique, alors ? »
L’océan est aussi le principal
régulateur du climat.
Il absorbe 90% de l’excès de chaleur
lié au réchauffement climatique.
Donc, pour protéger notre planète,
il faut protéger l’océan.
Le capitaine Cousteau nous a dit,
en une seule phrase :
« On protège ce qu’on aime,
et on aime ce qu’on connaît. »
Alors, qui connaît l’océan ?
Les spécialistes, les experts ?
Évidemment.
Mais ils sont tous mobilisés,
je vous rassure.
Depuis l’année dernière,
ils ont lancé au niveau international
la décennie des sciences océaniques,
la Décennie des Nations Unies
pour les sciences océaniques.
Donc, la mobilisation est mondiale
et ça nous impacte tous et toutes.
Tous, d’accord, mais on n’est pas
toutes et tous des chercheurs.
Et pourtant, on peut tous et toutes agir
pour mieux connaître, et donc
mieux protéger, notre océan.
Je m’appelle Christophe Desbois,
et je ne suis pas chercheur océanographe.
Je travaille au quotidien dans
un programme qui s’appelle ISblue,
pour traiter les enjeux de l’océan
et du réchauffement climatique,
et mon rôle, c’est de fédérer les équipes,
les grandes institutions françaises,
avec les grandes écoles d’ingénieurs,
des universités bretonnes, des centres
de recherche, tels que le CNRS, l’Ifremer,
mais aussi des entreprises,
des associations, des fondations,
qui sont toutes mobilisées
au chevet de l’océan.
On l’a appelé « ISblue »
parce qu’on voit un peu la vie en bleu.
Et mon rôle, c’est de faire
travailler ensemble les équipes.
Toutes les équipes.
Alors,
j’ai toujours le mal de mer.
La tuile.
Je travaille au quotidien avec la pointe
de l’océanographie
française du XXIᵉ siècle,
et j’ai le mal de mer.
Comme quoi tout arrive.
Donc, la science avance
et elle avance de plus en plus vite.
L’intelligence artificielle.
Réalité virtuelle.
Génétique.
Vous vous rendez compte des moyens ?
Eh bien, avec tous ces moyens,
on connaît, aujourd’hui,
environ
un peu moins de 5 %
de la biodiversité marine.
Je n’ai pas dit 50 %.
J’ai bien dit 5%.
En ordre de grandeur,
on a 240 000 espèces qui ont été
décrites par les scientifiques,
qui estiment à entre cinq et 10 millions,
le potentiel d’espèces
pour la biodiversité marine.
Donc c’est comme
si on était en train de dire :
« J’ai lu Harry Potter »,
mais vous ne savez pas encore
qu’il va à l’école des sorciers.
Heureusement, on sait cartographier
plein de choses aussi.
On sait cartographier la Lune,
on vient juste de recevoir
la dernière cartographie de Mars.
Bon, et les océans ?
On connaît les océans ?
Elle date de quand, la dernière
cartographie du fond des océans ?
À votre avis ?
Une date.
Elle date de 2030.
Enfin, s’ils finissent à temps.
Parce qu’il y a du travail.
Aujourd’hui, 80% de l’océan
n’a jamais été cartographié.
Donc, on connaît mieux la surface de la
Lune que la surface des fonds marins.
Vous voyez ?
Humblement, on ne connaît pas grand-chose.
Et pourtant,
souvenez-vous de ce que
nous disait Cousteau.
En gros, on connaît 5%,
donc on va protéger 5%.
Vous vous rendez compte ?
Pour protéger, il faut connaître.
On a véritablement
besoin de connaissances.
Et là on va entrer dans le dur.
Vous savez de quoi ils ont besoin,
les chercheurs ?
Du temps, globalement, on en a.
De l’argent, on en a encore un peu.
Ils ont vraiment besoin de quoi,
les chercheurs ?
Vraiment ?
De vous.
Les chercheurs ont besoin de vous.
C'est un appel au peuple.
Les chercheurs ont mis en place
des programmes de sciences citoyennes.
Donc, nous pouvons toutes
et tous, citoyennes, citoyens,
non scientifiques,
participer à l’avancée
de la science et de la connaissance.
Intéressant.
« Comment ça marche ? »,
vous allez me dire.
Eh bien, vous avez tous
une arme de connaissance
massive dans votre poche.
Un smartphone.
Vous pouvez tous réaliser
des observations, des mesures,
que vous pouvez transmettre.
L’important,
c’est de s’engager.
Donc concrètement vous allez sur internet,
vous tapez Open Sciences Participatives,
vous allez tomber sur le portail
de référence au niveau français
qui recense toutes
les initiatives en cours.
Il y a déjà 75 000 participants inscrits,
et un peu plus de
150 observatoires en place.
Vous pouvez vous engager.
Si vous êtes plaisancier,
vous pouvez participer.
Si vous préférez la pêche à pied,
Si vous aimez les sentiers côtiers,
vous pouvez participer aussi.
Ce qui compte, c'est l'envie d'agir.
C'est l'envie de faire ensemble.
Faire ensemble.
Ça résonne particulièrement en moi.
Ça me rappelle une rencontre
avec un marin au charisme incroyable,
le seul Père à bord après Dieu.
Je veux parler du Père Jaouen.
Le Père Jaouen,
il avait pour sacerdoce
d’embarquer à bord,
embarquer en mer des jeunes
qui étaient en délicatesse avec la Terre,
du moins avec ses lois,
et je pourrais résumer sa religion
en une seule phrase :
« L’important, c’est de mélanger. »
Il faut mélanger les gens.
À bord du Bel Espoir, j’ai embarqué
plusieurs semaines avec lui,
il y avait des gens de tous horizons.
Et, à bord,
j’y ai appris la joie de faire ensemble.
J’ai également appris la débrouillardise,
l’esprit d’équipage,
le faire ensemble.
C'est une aventure qui donne
du sens et de l'espoir.
Un sacré bel espoir.
Et ça m'émeut encore de pouvoir
vous en parler aujourd'hui.
L’important,
c’est l’humain,
c’est la rencontre.
Que vous soyez experte, expert, ou non,
l’important, c’est votre contribution.
Vous pouvez tous contribuer
à avancer dans la connaissance.
Les sciences citoyennes,
elles sont accessibles
au plus grand nombre.
C'est l'occasion de mobiliser
aussi d'autres approches.
Une approche plus low-tech,
qui soit utile,
accessible à toutes et tous.
On parle de démocratie technique.
Bien sûr qui soit plus durable
en termes de ressources employées,
en termes d’impact.
Une ingénierie décarbonée.
Avec la low-tech,
il ne s’agit pas d’opposer
la vision high-tech et low-tech.
Et, en océanographie moderne -
L’océanographie moderne
l’illustre très bien.
L’important,
c’est de travailler
sur les deux composantes.
Ce sont les deux faces d’une même pièce :
high-tech, low-tech.
Aujourd'hui, vous avez autour de la Terre
des satellites qui scrutent l'océan.
Ces satellites ont tous une marge
d’incertitude de mesure.
Les scientifiques ont besoin
de la mobilisation
de tous ceux qui vont en mer,
pour aller travailler des mesures in situ,
en mer.
Et pouvoir corriger
cette incertitude de mesure.
Voir corriger cette incertitude de mesure,
ça peut paraître
anodin.
Ça peut paraître impossible.
Et pourtant, des paramètres très simples :
température et pression atmosphérique
permettraient grandement
d’améliorer nos capacités.
Et on peut le faire
avec des capteurs low-tech.
Imaginez, si on mobilisait
les 60 000 bateaux de commerce
qui transitent en ce moment
à travers le monde.
Imaginez si on mobilisait les 200 000
plaisanciers sur les côtes françaises.
Imaginez si on mobilisait
les millions de Français
qui sont sur nos plages,
sur nos côtes, pour observer,
avec vos smartphones.
Eh bien, ça aiderait
considérablement la science,
et le partage de connaissances.
Je terminerai sur une seule phrase,
du poète et philosophe Paul Valéry :
« Un regard sur la mer,
c’est un regard sur le possible. »
Alors oui, il est possible d’agir pour
le climat en connaissant mieux les océans.
C'est notre planète bleue.
Agissons,
ensemble.
Merci à vous.
(Applaudissements)